products like caviar and vodka that were
once considered russian delicacies in
the us are now being called into
question with putin's invasion of
ukraine for example the past 20 years
the michelin star new york city
restaurant caviar roos has become well
known for spreads fit for an oligarch
but amid government bans on russian
imports that reputation is now coming
back to bite the family that owns the
restaurant it turns out they actually
immigrated from ukraine and their caviar
never came from russia it comes from
germany in fact no caviar in america
comes from russia government sanctions
against fish from russia like the salty
chic fish eggs are actually more
performative than anything else
caviar imported from russia worldwide
has dropped to a tiny fraction of the
global volume it commanded during the
1990s
russia popularized caviar from
wild-caught sturgeon that fish species
swam in the caspian and black seas
mostly and fishermen cut out the row
from the sturgeon and often toss the
fish back into the water to die both
russia and iran in particular became
huge producers of the expensive wild
caught caviar but after the sturgeon
population fell 30 percent producing
caviar from the fish was banned in the
early 2000s experts suggest that 2008
was the last time russian caviar was
served in america
still there are sanctions and in 2021
the us imported 1.2 billion dollars
worth of seafood from russia most of
that was pollock that sold at fast food
chains or smaller fish used for feed at
fish farms not one speck of that was
caviar
now seafood from russia is broadly
facing sanctions from countries looking
to punish russia for its unprovoked
attack on ukraine most high quality
caviar is now produced in farms located
across europe and in hungary italy
greece germany as well as stateside from
california to kentucky costco sources
its own occur caviar from a bulgarian
farm in the black sea
the largest supply of caviar in the
world meanwhile comes from one farm in
china it accounts for 35 of global
caviar sales its tins are shipped
overnight around the world to 23
countries including 22 michelin-starred
restaurants in france as well as five in
new york
russian president vladimir putin himself
has even eaten the chinese produced
caviar at least twice once at the 2016
g20 summit in hangzhou where the caviar
farm is located and the other during a
one-on-one meeting with chinese
president xi ji ping the chinese farm
was actually set up by bill holst a
third generation corn farmer based in
wisconsin chinese investors approached
holst who had been turning around other
failed caviar farms to help them
transform a small sturgeon farm in the
country into china's first caviar
operation holst became the largest
individual shareholder and the only one
from america he sold his remaining stake
in 2018. he reinvested the profit in
three farms in france italy and germany
his caviar ranges from four hundred
dollars a pound to as much as two
thousand dollars a pound but even with
the rising price of transportation fuel
and labor the future of the caviar
business is bright he says demand for
caviar remains very high